做當充選對股票你就先贏一半了
今天我不嘗試直接教你兩種
神術懸鼓法
一個只要五分鐘
另一個甚至不用一分鐘
而且騙我會透露
選完股後真正的賺錢關鍵
都是我最真實的獲利方法
一定要看到最後
大家好我是摩卡
我專職當充八年了
有過五年教學經驗
帶過3000多位學員
再教你怎麼懸鼓之前
我們先搞清楚
為什麼要這樣選
你只要記住三個關鍵
少一個都會讓你當充不斷碰壁
第一個波動
來考考你
左邊跟右邊這兩檔股票
你覺得哪一檔適合當中
當然是右邊
因為有波動才有價差可以賺
如果你選到左邊這種死股股會怎麼樣呢
第一進去之後動動不動卡一整天
第二個好不容易漲
第二個一檔也不夠你賺回交易成本
結果就是時間浪費錢也賠掉了
所以第一關股票一定要有波動
第二個亮能再來一個小測驗
這兩檔股票你選哪一檔
我一定選右邊
關鍵就是亮能
也就是這檔股票的
股拖買賣帳處
量能就像股票的協議
量能大代表市場關注度高
預計買賣的人多
你進場出場才會順暢
如果你去衝一檔
沒量的股票會發生什麼事
你想買的時候
買不到理想的價格
想賣的時候
還賣不掉
就有可能因為流動性不足
會以破用更差的價格出場
白白多賠了幾檔
最可怕的是
大戶只要下一筆大單
就能讓股價爆漲爆裂
你完全被玩弄於股漲之間
所以第二關
股票一定要有量能
第三 價格
最後一題
這四大股票
只看他們的價格
你會選擇哪兩檔來做當充呢
我的答案是
為什麼呢
這跟你的交易成本有絕對的關係
我們來算一下
在台股做當充
你的成本有
手續費和交易稅
手續費以三折計算是
當充交易稅減半後是
1.5
一買一賣
總成本大約是
不會算 沒關係
您只要知道要大於0.23%就好了
舉個例子
105元的股票
跳一檔0.5元大約0.47%
已經遠超過交易成本0.23%了
所以跳一檔您就賺錢了
60元的股票
跳一檔0.1元大約0.16%
要跳兩檔才能回本
但還是很容易獲利
但是91元的股票
跳一檔0.1元不到0.11%
至少要跳三檔才有辦法回本
45元的股票也一樣
跳一檔0.05元大約0.11%
一樣要跳三檔才賺的到錢
獲利效率非常的差
但總不能在選股的時候
一檔一檔慢慢算吧
來 資單表送給你
把你在看的股票價格
直接對應過去
就知道跳幾檔才會回本啦
另外 我再教你一個
高手都在用的小技巧
可以解決這種價格成本的問題
讓你不管做多少錢的股票
都是跳一檔
就能有明顯獲利
那就是使用股票期貨
股票期貨的交易成本
低到驚人
手續費低到可以不用理會
它的交易稅是契約價值的
10萬分之2也就是0.002%
跟股票的0.15%天差地圖
所以你用股票期貨完全可以不用再煩惱
價格這個問題
只要專心尋找有波動有亮能的股票就好了
綜合以上三點
我們要找的就是
有波動有亮能價格好衝的股票
好 邏輯講完了
我們接著實戰操作
第一種
5分鐘通用旋股法
很簡單
我以XQ為例
打開APP之後
點下面的行情
再點左上角的三條杠
選擇抬股往下拉
找到台股選股
點進去之後選第二個
亮能排行
最後點成交重心股
這個列表裡面的股票
都是今天市場上
亮能最集中的焦點
他們一定符合我們亮能的標準
接下來你一眼少過去
拿股價去對應我給你的標格
先找跳一檔回本的股票
點進去看他的走勢圖
如果走勢是上下有波動
不是一條石水
恭喜你
這檔就是你的候選人
可以加入自選清單
等待你的進場訊號吧
第二種
天文秘技1分鐘極速懸鼓法
如果你覺得5分鐘還是太慢
或者你想直接看
我怕我本人最近在關注什麼股票
那我再教你一招更快
全市場只有我這樣做
就是直接去看我頻道的SHORTS短片
我每個月都會在SHORTS裡面
公開我最近正在觀察
或實際操作的股票名單
你可以直接超過去用
這招是不是更快
但是選對股票只是開始而已
怎麼做才是你賺賠的真正關鍵
我自己專精的是極短線當中
我的核心就是觀察
盤中當下最即時的主力痕跡
比如說圍賣圍賣單的變化與順序
大單小單的敲進與轉折等等
找到這些痕跡跟著主力大戶站在同一邊
他們多我做多
他們空我也反恐
經過我的統計後
這樣的做法勝率高達八成
這個極短線當中的交易策略
我已經把整個進場出場
停損保利的SOP全部整理成一滿完整的課程
一鍵下方的資訊欄有免費視聽的連結
歡迎你點進去看看這套策略是不是合理
如果你對當充是認真的
我相信這套策略一定能幫助到你
我是摩卡
也是你的交易教練
我們下次見